[Aplausos]
[Música]
turquía es el diego armando maradona de
los países también tuvo un pasado
glorioso pero en los últimos años cada
vez que salen en los medios es porque ha
ocurrido algo realmente malo
[Música]
nos habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
explicando lo que está pasando en
turquía y creedme se trata de un
auténtico peligro y no por si alguno se
lo estaba preguntando esta vez no es
culpa de donald trump es más las
sanciones de eeuu son sólo la punta del
iceberg un iceberg que puede hacer que
muchos barcos se hundan y en este caso
los barcos son los bancos europeos
fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
turquía es el puente entre europa y asia
hablamos de un país con tanta población
como alemania un país donde europa ha
estado invirtiendo desde hace décadas
empresas fábricas y sobre todo muchos
préstamos para que os hagáis una idea
habéis oído hablar del bbv se trata del
segundo banco más grande de españa pues
bien turquía es su tercer mercado más
importante en otras palabras que si los
turcos estornudan muchos europeos se van
a resfriar qué decís que todavía no
estáis asustados pues atentos turquía es
uno de los miembros más importantes de
la otan
después de eeuu son el ejército más
numeroso de la alianza y además es uno
de los pocos países de mayoría musulmana
que tiene una constitución laica al
menos por el momento y si habéis oído
bien hemos dicho por el momento lo
cierto es que al presidente turco recep
tayip erdogán
eso del laicismo le suena bastante mal
erdogán es algo así como el anakin
skywalker de la política empieza siendo
el bueno de la película pero todos
sabemos que tarde o temprano terminará
cayendo en el lado oscuro
[Música]
en este caso el lado oscuro es una
mezcla entre fanatismo religioso y
populismo de la vieja escuela
erdogán se presenta como el defensor de
los turcos de a pie
esos turcos que viven en las zonas
rurales de coney a completamente ajenos
al glamour de estambul son los turcos
que no cobran grandes sueldos y que
mantienen un estilo de vida tradicional
y de quien hace falta defenderlos pues
por supuesto de la conspiración
occidental que quiere acabar con la
turquía de toda la vida eso explica que
para la propaganda de erdogán noticias
como estas sean tan importantes
eeuu impone sanciones a oficiales turcos
por un pastor estadounidense detenido
sin embargo todo esto no es más que la
punta del iceberg la crisis de turquía
se lleva cociendo desde hace más de dos
años y no sólo hablamos de una crisis
política en realidad lo más problemático
de turquía es la economía podríamos
estar hablando de una venezuela en
miniatura a las puertas de europa y os
preguntaréis pero qué está pasando en
turquía que ha pasado en este país para
que hayan caído en el lado oscuro de la
economía de verdad hay razones para
asustarse hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
erdogán el salvador turquía es un país
famoso por varias cosas santa sofía el
kebab y la inflación
[Música]
desde el año 1970 hasta el año 2000
turquía sufría unas inflaciones brutales
muchos años llegaron a superar el cien
por cien
eso significa que de un año para otro
los precios se duplicaban y qué pasa
cuando tienes tantísima inflación y
estás a las puertas de europa pues que
te conviertes en algo así como la
disneylandia de la mano de obra barata
empresas como renault o peugeot
construyeron montones de fábricas en
turquía y diréis en principio eso son
noticias buenas para un país no pues sí
y a la vez no
por ejemplo en los años 60 renault montó
una fábrica e impulsa que es una ciudad
al norte de turquía producir coches en
bursa era muy barato para renault sin la
lira turca se devaluaba año tras año
renault tenía que pagar cada vez sueldos
más bajos sin embargo una vez ganaban el
dinero lo guardaban en el país pues
obviamente no
[Música]
cómo
y el dinero pierde valor continuamente
lo mejor que puedes hacer es sacarlo lo
antes posible así que turquía estaba
condenada a no progresar hasta el año
2003 año en el que erdogán llega al
poder
[Música]
y el gran objetivo de erdogán era poner
la inflación por debajo del 10% y tan
pronto como lo consiguió la economía
turca dio un giro de 180 grados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de repente muchas empresas europeas se
pusieron a invertir en turquía y eso
incluye a los bancos uno de ellos es
bbva el segundo más importante de españa
y lo hizo a lo grande para bbv a turquía
representa su tercer mercado
[Música]
los años 2000 turquía se puso de moda
seguridad jurídica significa que las
empresas pueden reinvertir en el país
así que en menos de 10 años los turcos
pasaron de cobrar unos 800 dólares al
mes de media a superar los 1.200 dólares
pero no sólo es en estos primeros años
de erdogán aparecieron nuevos sectores
como el turismo
[Aplausos]
turquía pasó de tener 13 millones de
turistas a 39 y qué me decís de las
empresas turcas habéis oído hablar
alguna vez de turkish airlines en los
años 90 turkish airlines era una empresa
de aviación más pero al poder invertir
sus beneficios se han terminado
convirtiendo en un líder de aviación a
nivel global
[Música]
y no creáis que hablamos de un caso
aislado si hay un ejemplo del milagro
turco ese es el dif holdings hablamos de
un grupo de alimentación que empezó
siendo una pastelería familiar y que ha
terminado comprando marcas
internacionales como la belga chocolates
godiva o la británica united biscuits
para que os hagáis una idea
yildiz ha terminado siendo la tercera
empresa de alimentación del mundo en
otras palabras que la economía turca
estaba on fire y cuando la economía está
on fire a nadie parece preocuparle que
erdogán hubiera estado en la cárcel por
militar en un grupo radical a fin de
cuentas el país seguía siendo
democrático y erdogán era la rockstar
del mundo árabe el elegido para conducir
a todo el mundo islámico hacia el lado
luminoso de la política
por aquellos años turquía se veía cada
vez más como un país europeo a punto de
entrar a la mismísima unión europea como
dato curioso en 2003 llegaron a ganar el
festival de eurovisión pero ya sabéis
las negociaciones para entrar en europa
se extendieron durante años y qué pasó
entonces pues quier dogan se le acabó la
paciencia y dijo ajá así que no soy lo
suficientemente cool como para entrar en
vuestro club verdad pues os vais a
enterar porque eso de ser tan occidental
con separación de poderes laicismo y no
sé qué más se ha terminado ha llegado el
momento de
la nueva erdogán o mix en los últimos
cinco años las cosas han empezado a
complicarse para erdogán para empezar
han salido todo tipo de casos de
corrupción que le implican directamente
pero sin duda alguna lo más problemático
han sido noticias como esta
ataque al aeropuerto atatürk de estambul
41 muertos y más de 230 heridos los
atentados del dax han llevado el
terrorismo islámico y el caos a las
calles de turquía y el daño sobre el
turismo ha sido inmediato en dos años ha
caído un 25% y esto es preocupante si
tenemos en cuenta que el turismo supone
el 13 por ciento de la economía turca
pero hay más datos negativos la
inversión extranjera ha caído a la mitad
y os preguntaréis por qué pues
básicamente por dos razones una es que
cada vez hay menos probabilidades de que
el país entre en la unión europea y dos
el propio erdogán y es que mis queridos
amigos de visual política el radicalismo
islámico no sólo es un peligro político
también es un peligro económico
el presidente turco erdogán dice que las
tasas de interés son la madre de todos
los males y la lira turca cae según
erdogán la ortodoxia económica es un
invento de occidente para desestabilizar
a turquía y eso de prestar dinero a
cambio de interés en contra del islam
así que por su propia cuenta y riesgo ha
llegado al banco central turco y ha
obligado a bajar las tasas de interés al
máximo posible y empezar a imprimir
billetes como si no existiera mañana y
qué pasa si el banco central se niega
pues estas fueron sus palabras textuales
el banco central no puede utilizar su
independencia para rechazar las señales
que le da el presidente
erdogán en declaraciones para bloomberg
en otras palabras que tras el intento
del golpe de estado de 2016
erdogán ha caído definitivamente en el
lado oscuro
[Música]
según él puede dirigir la economía a su
antojo y todo argumento racional en
contra de su política económica es una
conspiración occidental para que os
hagáis una idea a nombrado como ministro
de finanzas a su propio yerno el nuevo
paradigma económico de turquía no es ni
liberal ni socialdemócrata es la erdogán
omic
necesitas dinero para pagar tu gasto
público lo imprime es que las empresas
turcas se quejan pues llenas el mercado
con crédito barato en menos de dos años
los bancos turcos han prestado más de 50
mil millones de dólares a las pequeñas
empresas
y todo esto prácticamente sin tipos de
interés el resultado una mega
devaluación de la liga turca en el año
2014 el dólar estadounidense se cambiaba
por aproximadamente 2 liras y media en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
el dólar se cambia por más de 6 libras
es decir que la divisa turca ha bajado
casi en la tercera parte de su valor en
dólares y eso explica que la inflación
en 2017 llegará al 11 9%
lo que estáis pensando 11 9 puestos eso
tampoco es una inflación tan alta en
argentina sin ir más lejos tienen tres
veces más inflación lo cierto es que
hace falta tiempo desde que una divisa
se devalúa hasta que la inflación se
empieza a notar y quiénes son los
primeros en sufrir los efectos de una
devaluación pues las empresas que tenían
préstamos en bancos extranjeros y no
creáis que son pocas os acordáis de
yield y holdings ese gigante de la
alimentación pues mirad mirad
[Música]
el dueño turco de chocolates godiva
reestructura una deuda de 6.500 millones
de dólares se estima que la deuda
extranjera que tienen las empresas
turcas sobrepasa los 300 mil millones de
dólares para que os hagáis una idea eso
es lo que han tostado todos los rescates
a la economía de grecia y mientras tanto
la inflación que aparece los ciudadanos
de a pie va creciendo poco a poco este
año 2018 ya ha alcanzado el 15 por
ciento y las previsiones ajenas al
gobierno turco dicen que a principios de
2019 llegará al 22%
[Música]
la calificación crediticia de turquía es
rebajada profundamente al 'bono basura'
mientras standard and poor's predice una
recesión el próximo año el resto le
tenemos que sumar las sanciones que
trump está imponiendo a turquía las
razones detrás de estas sanciones son
tan complejas que hablaremos de ellas en
otro vídeo mientras tanto en mitad de
toda esta crisis hay un actor secundario
que tiene mucho que perder la unión
europea'
[Música]
bancos como el español bbva el francés
bnp paribas o el italiano unicredit le
han prestado más de 190.000 millones de
euros a las empresas turcas y por el
momento el bbv haya perdido la mitad del
valor de sus inversiones en este país
así que ya os podéis imaginar el agujero
que tendría un colapso de turquía de
momento erdogán ha dicho que iba a pedir
un rescate al fondo monetario
internacional- ni va a imponer control
de capitales ahora bien puede realmente
mantener su palabra pues lo cierto es
que no lo sabemos por el momento catar y
china han dicho que van a intentar
ayudar pero todavía es pronto para ver
lo que va a ocurrir
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros puede turquía a convertirse en
la venezuela europea hasta qué punto
esto puede desatar una nueva crisis en
toda europa es más poder dogan
arrastrarnos a todos al lado oscuro
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
teniente